- Hi, everyone.
Sal Khan here from Khan Academy,
and I'm here with Mark Risher
who is director of Product
Management at Android at Google
to talk a little bit
about device security.
So Mark, welcome.
And my first question is
what is device security?
Are we talking about somehow keeping
our mobile devices secure?
- We are talking about that.
We're trying to say, how do
you make sure your device,
your mobile phone, your tablet,
anything that's digital these days
is guarded against unwanted access?
That could be coming from
hackers in some other country,
it could be coming from
someone in the room next door.
In all cases, we wanna give you
the right level of
protection and security.
- And I just wanna make
this tangible for folks,
'cause I think we all have a sense that,
okay, you know, we don't
want people messing around
on our phones or on our
tablets or our laptops,
but when has device security
not gone well for folks?
(Mark chuckles)
- There's more and more
information on these devices.
You know, we trust them with,
not just whatever the
application itself is asking us,
but often it knows where
you are in the world,
your location, it knows
what you've typed in
and what you've searched,
it knows whom you're communicating with.
All these different dimensions,
you know, they can be exploited.
For the most part, good
things are happening
and I'm definitely an
optimist in this space.
But we wanna make sure
that people understand what's going on,
understand who has
access to the information
and then they can make
the appropriate decisions
and trade-offs so that they
get the right level of control
without sacrificing all that's
really cool about technology.
I really try not to frighten people,
but to say, you know, what could happen?
What could happen if all of
your location information
were out there is, you
know, on a continuum,
from it could be embarrassing
to bad things could
happen in the real world
if someone knows exactly
where you're going
to be at a given time,
to they cross correlate that information
with something else and they use that
to maybe send you a scam,
send you a phishing warning, send you,
you know, some sort of
crime could take place.
There really is quite a
breadth and unfortunately,
these criminals are very motivated
and they're seeing positive results,
so they do keep innovating.
And that's again why we want people
to have that right level of protection,
that right level of control
over their sensitive
data on their devices.
- Yeah, one of the things that
immediately comes into mind
in other videos we've produced,
we talk about how
two-factor authentication
is really important,
because for someone to be able
to get access to your password
and your device is very unlikely.
But to your point, if they
do get access to your device
or if they're able to track
your movements in some way,
they might be able to fake being you
a little bit better and get
access to all sorts of things
or pretend to be you and
embarrass you at minimum,
or do worse, access to your
bank accounts, et cetera.
- Yeah, that's actually the one
that I'm even more scared of.
People might say, you know,
"I don't do anything suspicious.
I don't do anything
risky. What do I care?"
But the problem is that then
what the attackers wanna do
is leverage your reputation
to go after someone else.
And that can be terrible.
Some of you may have seen what we call
the "Mugged in London" scam.
You get a message that looks
like it's from your uncle
or your cousin or your
grandmother or what have you,
saying, "I've been attacked.
Please wire money to me."
And this is a scam.
It's coming from the attackers
who broke into that person's account
and then sent it to all
their family members.
So again, even if you're not worried
that you yourself have sensitive data,
what you really don't want
is somebody taking your reputation
and using that to bootstrap their way
into even more heinous crimes.
- Wow. That's so powerful.
I could imagine if someone
close to me texted me right now
and said that, I'd be like, "Oh yeah,
how do I help them?"
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's a good word of warning.
- And then both parties
feel guilty about that.
It's terrible in all around.
It's really this awful
exploitation. I hate it.
- Okay, whether or not
you intended to do it,
you scared me a little
bit, which I think is good.
- But there's hope. There's hope.
We can work together, Sal.